alors il acheta pour porto toujours moi
c'est toujours dans le sud
toujours sous le soleil des impôts dgi
indochinois sénégalais maliens malgache
ils ont combattu pour la france lors de
conflits armés la compagnie mémoires
vives les 10 à nos morts à ces soldats
des guerres mondiales et à leur
descendance
c'est essentiellement des recherches
historiques on a essayé de compenser ça
en sûrs et en 1h15 de montrer un maximum
de choses enfin de dire il était là ils
étaient là ils étaient là ils étaient là
par tous a priori on avait appris qu'il
est avec nous c'est à dire nous les
blancs on relativise un peu les choses
quand on apprend qu effectivement et à
tout le continent africain qui se
mobilisent quoi et que la première armée
d'afrique
la véritable armée française est
constitué à 60 70 % de l'afrique alors
africains musulmans de faire tout le
monde et l'aude aux carences du chef de
village créé à la suite des émeutes de
2005 à nos morts à 10 ans cette année le
spectacle a été labellisé centenaire de
la guerre 14-18 par la région alsace et
actions mémorielle de transmission par
la mission du centenaire
nous on a utilisé notre nos moyens
d'expression aux armes à prendre une
expression de césaire nos armes
miraculeuses donc on est on est des
poètes on n'est pas des historiens on
s'est quand même dit que on raconter
quelque chose qui est historique et
qu'il fallait pas qu'on raconte non plus
n'importe quoi donc bien sûr il ya des
traits qui sont grossis bien sûr il ya
des choses qui sont un peu romancée hip
hop chant et théâtre urbain des styles
artistiques résolument contemporain pour
traiter une histoire française qu'il ne
faut pas oublier
elle a battu la mairie il va venir vite
à l'autre parce que vous êtes
c'est pas glorieux